the fourth user of one for all is a
character who is mostly shrouded in
mystery
in chapter 257 of the manga all might
research
all the previous users he could find and
compiled a notebook full of information
in the words of bakago there was a
detailed summary for the fifth
sixth and seventh users including stuff
like their cause of death and their
quirks
but when it came to the fourth user
allmight had intentionally scribbled out
some of the details
when asked about this allmight simply
said that he's worried about deku
and that there's something about one for
all that he hasn't figured out yet
i will admit that it's never specified
which part of the fourth user's story
has been left out
for example it could be his quirk that
was scribbled out or it could be his
cause of death
or perhaps his morality you know maybe
he wasn't such a good guy
at this stage we just don't know what
all might was hiding
but today i'm gonna propose a theory
that i think would explain his actions
at the crux of this theory we have two
issues number one
is that all might is hiding something
about the fourth user
and number two is that whatever he's
hiding it relates to an
unknown element of one for all i mean
baghdad literally said like did you
figure out something about one for all
and all might just replies not yet so
clearly
the existence of the fourth user it
raises some questions about one fraud
itself
to tackle the first problem i mentioned
let's assume for the purpose of this
video
that it's the fourth user's quirk that
was hidden if that is the case
all might would only hide this power
because it's something that
deku would immediately recognize and
perhaps be
fearful of using i say that because if
the quirk was simply one that was
hard to master or perhaps a dangerous
quirk that wouldn't stop deku i mean
this is a guy who trained for like 10
months to master a quirk that could have
potentially
exploded his body if there's one person
in the world who's willing to
try out a dangerous or harmful quirk
it's this guy
furthermore hiding the ability wouldn't
really help anyone
because as we saw with black whip the
quirk may just manifest itself
out of the blue at some point and just
hurt other people
by all might's own admission he doesn't
want deku's remaining quirks to just
explode out of nowhere so the only
reason he would hide the fourth user's
quirk
is because it's it's just a piece of
information that midoriya isn't ready to
handle just yet
if the fourth user's power is a quirk
that we're already familiar with
then that would of course raise many
questions about one for all
and also it would just be very confusing
for deku to hear this at this stage
so almight is protecting him by not
revealing this information
this brings us to the second issue which
is the secret of one for all that all
might hasn't quite worked out yet
in my opinion at least this secret has
been hiding in plain sight
and would explain why the fourth user's
quirk is what i think it could be
just for some context we know that deku
is the first
and only user of one for all to unlock
all the various quirks inside
by default this means that the previous
users didn't know their quirks were
being stored inside one for all
this is most obvious when it comes to
nana shimura and i'll explain why
in a flashback to all might's younger
days we see that she passes one for all
to him when he was a quirkless teenager
so probably around 14 years old you know
just before he went to ua
it wasn't until four years later when
all might was 18 years old
that she died at the hands of all for
one so during that four year period
the embers of one floor definitely would
have died out within maybe like the
first year
therefore during this final battle with
all for one nanashimura
all might in gran torino you know she
didn't have one four at this time
but she did have her original float
quirk we know this because number one
there's a zero percent chance that she
would fight all for one quirkless i mean
how ridiculous would it be to fight a
guy with almost infinite quirks with
zero quotes it wouldn't make sense
so clearly she had float at this time
point number two
no one knew their powers were being
stored inside one for all anyway
so naturally if you don't know what's
being stored then you're still going to
have your original quirk all common
sense would dictate
that during this final battle nana
shamura did have float
despite passing one fraud to all might
as a direct consequence of that
you guys know what this means right
there are two versions of this power
one version that nana shimura used her
whole life
and a copy that was stored inside one
for all you know
all these years with deku being the
first person to use it
the only thing that makes sense is that
one for all secret ability that all
might hasn't figured out yet
is the power to duplicate quirks whoever
possesses one for all
has a copy of their quirks stored inside
it whilst they retain
use of the original nana shimura is
literally evidence of this
because is anyone really gonna argue
that she fought all for one quirkless i
highly doubt it
clearly she still must have had float on
her side meanwhile in
all might's own body float was secretly
residing inside the one floor quirk so
there were two copies
all for one's brother is a notable
exception for very obvious reasons
given that his transfer quirk is is
literally 50
of one for all without the transfer
quirk one for all doesn't even exist
whereas these other quirks like float
and black whip and so on
they're simply bonuses and you know
copies of the original
but anyway this secret ability is what
brings me to the conclusion of this
theory
we've already established that the
fourth user had a quirk
that deku just can't be made aware of
right now and we also know
that one for all has the power to
duplicate quirks
hence why nana shamura was still able to
use float despite it residing inside one
for all
after she had already passed it on with
all this being the case
we can now turn our attention back to
the fourth user whose most notable uh
his most notable thing is the distinct
marking on his face
whatever his quirk was there's a version
of it inside one for all
and another version of it that he held
on to after this moment when he passed
on one for all
this means that all for one could have
still stolen this guy's original quote
when we look at this mark on his face it
resembles the effects of a quirk that we
are already familiar with
but instead of just telling you let me
show you
when we compare side by side the marking
on the fourth user's face
next to the effects of decay when
shiguraki activated it for the first
time
you can clearly see that the jagged
nature of the lines
bears a very strong resemblance on top
of that
before shigaraki ever used decay for the
first time he was brought home by
this man in a suit who is so obviously
all for one
this is backed up by the fact that in
chapter 281
it was revealed that nana was worried
about all for one discovering her family
because in her words he'd be sure to
exploit their connection
let me say that again guys nana shimura
was worried about all for one
finding her family because he was going
to exploit their connection
horikoshi is spelling it out for us here
all for one discovered her family
and did exactly what she was afraid of
by giving her grandson
the terrible decay quirk that led to the
obviously led to the series of events
that we're witnessing now
this is why all might is trying to keep
it secret from deku for the time being
because one day deku will unlock decay
just like shigaraki decay was originally
held by the fourth user of one for all
and due to the nature of the quirk
two copies were made one which was
stolen by all for one
and another which is still inside one
for all
but of course that is just a theory like
i said at the beginning this is all
based on the fact
that all might is hiding the fourth
user's quirk
now obviously we know he's hiding
information but we were never told
specifically that it was the fourth
user's
quirk that he was hiding so let's just
wait and see regarding that
obviously if he's not hiding the quirk
and it's something else then fair enough
this theory is completely redundant
but um if he is hiding the quirk we will
we will see
we will see whatever your thoughts on
this
let me know down below and thank you for
watching